so let me welcome all of you to this
this free webinar that we're hosting by
reason al friedrich nietzsche on three
noble responses to the problem of life
we're going to be talking a lot about
his first early work the birth of
tragedy out of the spirit of music is
the full title so i'm going to introduce
myself since i don't know some of you
and i think some of you may know me only
through my videos i'm dr. Greg Sadler
I'm the president of reason IO which is
essentially a mom-and-pop company here
in Milwaukee Wisconsin we do a lot of
different things which you can see if
you if you go on to our website I'm
among other things a popular online
educator on figures in philosophy I've
had content out on Nietzsche for about
close to seven years now and people have
been watching it and referencing it in
their classes and in other venues and
I've been teaching Nietzsche really
since I began teaching philosophy
classes nineteen years ago
he's a nice foil ethics was my very
first class that I got to teach and I'm
Anna juggle him in as sort of a critic
of different types of morality so if
somebody I've been looking at here's
what we're going to do I've got some
some introductory stuff and then I've
got five main batches of topics that
we're going to discuss and when I say
discuss I mean I'm just going to talk
about these and I'm going to go through
these rather brief so that we can stay
more or less on time and then we have 20
minutes reserved for Q&A and discussion
we try to have it about the close to
half and half for these webinars so
people have plenty of opportunity I'm
just going to keep everybody on mute for
the time being until we get to the Q&A
and discussion once we get there you can
you can unmute yourself you can always
write questions in the chat box and I
will I will answer them once we get to
that part
so a couple questions to start us off
Nietzsche talks about there being a
problem of life and we should ask
yourself well is there really a problem
of life what what does that mean and if
we think that there is such a thing
maybe you know universally or maybe just
for certain people then we can ask
ourselves is there a best response to
that problem or the different people
pick different responses and that that's
okay
one of the key questions that Nietzsche
is grappling with our esthetic responses
as opposed to moral responses or
political responses are primarily
aesthetic responses valid and then as
we're thinking about this this issue and
about this text we should we should ask
ourselves well what does our own culture
actually offer us do we have an
embarrassment of riches because we have
access to so much stuff or are we in
some ways starving in the midst of
plenty these are all legitimate
questions for us and Nietzsche is going
to discuss these issues within what we
can call a developmental history some
people like to call this a genealogy
right because he's going to talk later
on about a genealogy of morals and so
you know this first work is the giver to
tragedy right or the the birth of
tragedy
you see Apollo and Dionysus over there
and one of the nice illustrations from
from I think and early version of this
so what we're going to do here is I'm
going to introduce you to a couple key
ideas and Nietzsche's work the birth of
tragedy out of the spirit of music later
on this week for those who are
interested we actually have two
intensive online seminars they're the
same seminar just at different times to
allow people worldwide to participate we
were able to cover most time zones and
we're going to go deeper into these
ideas and add additional discussion so
if you find yourself really interested
in this then then that may be for you if
this is the little bite-sized chunk that
we're going to do today is enough for
that that's good too so let's talk
about the first topic the birth of
tragedy out of the spirit of music like
I put here this is Nietzsche's first
main literary production it's not his
his only work of course but he you know
it's the one that he is sort of tying
his his wagon to at that point and he is
very critical of it if you look at the
editions that we currently have he
becomes quite critical of it when he's
looking back on it so you probably want
to read the foreword that he has one key
idea of course is this issue of the
problem of life that we're going to talk
about shortly and another key idea is
the noble responses so let's let's jump
into these ideas this is his first main
work it's published in 1872 if you've
read it you you realize that it's rather
difficult it's a quite a tangled work
Nietzsche himself actually admits this
when he's talking about it later on and
it doesn't get a great positive
reception as a matter of fact one critic
will little tack it already at the
beginning and it contains a lot of
important ideas worked out more fully in
later works so Nietzsche says this is
part of his self-criticism the question
was one of existence of the value placed
on existence and he asks is pessimism
inevitably a sign of decadence or is
there a strong pessimism this is a
typically Nietzschean frame framework or
theme he calls it youthful heavy-handed
he at one point calls it an embarrassing
book for himself so that that's kind of
an issue the interesting issue he also
at that time he was quite taken with
with vogner and he is going to revise
that later on we'll talk about that
towards the end but he you know in his
his self-criticism he says it was a
mistake to view vogner as any sort of
embodiment of something higher he really
didn't met
you're up when we look at the problem of
life Nietzsche is framing this in terms
of he calls it the problem of life or
the problem of existence and the
question is what is the meaning of
existence what justifies the life that
we live in which we toil we suffer we
endure pain things don't seem to make
sense maybe all of our Labour's are
going for nothing this is an age-old
question about the human condition that
is dealt with in philosophy and
religious texts and literature and so
all sorts of responses are actually
possible for this and Nietzsche's going
to lay out what some of these are so
here we get to really the core of our
our webinar today the three noble
responses very late in the work Nature
writes in age after age the same
phenomenon recurs over and over the avid
will finds means to perpetuate it
creatures in life by spreading over
existence the blandishments of illusion
one man is enthralled by oops one one
man is enthralled by the Socratic zest
for knowledge and it's persuaded that he
can staunch the eternal wound of being
with its help another is beguiled by the
veil of art which flutters tantalizing
before his eyes that's the Apollonia yet
another is buoyed up by the metaphysical
solace that life flows on indestructible
beneath the whirlpool of appearances the
three kinds of illusion I have named
answer only two noble nature's who
resent the burden of existence more
deeply than the rest so here he's
actually laying out what the three noble
responses are Socratic Apollonian and
Dionysian these are what we're going to
discuss so let's talk about the the
second main topic what is this this
business about the D&E siak and the
Apollonian we're going to look first at
intoxication and dream because that's
where it Nietzsche begins then and we'll
talk about what what each of these is so
this is a contrast very early on in the
war
Nietzsche says both of these are ways of
in some sense disguising the nature of
existence from us because if we take it
raw we can't actually endure it so the
dream is Apollonian it's it's identified
with Apollo the God who actually sends
messages to human beings through dreams
there's some structure to it some
illusion some play a world that you can
work with contrast that the sort of and
don't think about nightmares but think
about you know nice nice dreams where
you are maybe floating or meeting
interesting people intoxication is at
the other end of the scale
it's D&S yet you're losing the self in
some sort of primal unity in a dynamism
in effect in in some sort of chaos and
so the DIA misiek when he just sees this
as more primal than the Apollonia n-- he
doesn't see it as simply the way things
are if we strip away all the appearances
he talks sort of on the edge of that but
he but he also sees this as a response
and you know it's characterized by dance
by music by effects our emotions even
even frenzy and the self gets lost
within the dynamic suffering
contradictory and he doesn't say that
you know when we realize that all things
are one that it's a really nice you know
experience or something like that he's
saying that this is actually in some
respect terrifying
now that the world and its core is
actually shot through with contradiction
and the DNA siakam braces that the
Apollonia is something at the other
extreme and he tells us that Apollo is
the founder of States he imposes order
restrictions and limits you know he
talks about the Delphic Oracle with
these models of nothing too much and
know thyself he also talks about the
Apollonian as something almost like an
armed camp you know setting up a citadel
and you might have in mind something
like the fortifications in athens
themselves
involves a distinction of the self apart
from other things what he calls the
Principia individual Yanis the principle
of individuation and what this does is
it imposes a kind of structure onto the
DNA see and you could say it makes the
DNA Sein freeze and its movement and if
it goes too far he says it can become
frozen in Egyptian rigidity we know a
bit more about Egypt now I would say
than they did in Nietzsche's time so we
don't necessarily have to have this
stereotype but the view was that the
dinar twas you know too rigid to frozen
so let's talk about how these come
together then in Greek tragedy the DNA
seein and the Apollonian they're
identified by Nietzsche with different
art forms and we're going to want to see
how these art forms come into attention
and there's there's sort of a brief
shining moment which lasts actually
several decades where things are working
and Aeschylus and Sophocles our prime
representatives of this and I want to
Prometheus since Nietzsche actually uses
that as an example in here as a prime
person to to talk about
so nature writes what aesthetic effect
is produced when the Apollonian and DNA
see act forces of art usually separate
are made to work alongside each other
what does he mean by that
he means that oftentimes we can identify
different art forms with the DNA siak or
with the Apollonia and they're more or
less exclusive so you know music I had
mentioned in its origin is d in this in
for Nietzsche the plastic arts like
sculpture are prime examples the
Apollonia inform is imposed it's it's a
silent it's still when it comes to
poetry lyric poetry is is more
the initial lyric poetry would be you
know a lot of these these great writers
including some who are in some respect
more more Apollonia in like Solon but
but also some of those who are really
pushing the envelope you could say and
then epic poetry like that of Homer
would be Apollonian it's creating almost
like a dream world that you get to
participate in through observing the the
spectacle that's being created through
through language and tragedy is in some
respect a kind of mixture but it's not
just a mixture it is getting something
that goes higher and higher and higher
in its dynamic tension and nature
devotes a lot of discussion to the
chorus and the role of the course and
I'm we can talk about that in the Q&A if
you're really interested in that you
know long story short he thinks that the
chorus represents the V and misiek sort
of impulse and the chorus is a way of
walling off the V play the action from
the world but it also involves the
spectator and at the same time you have
a DNF C act chorus and it just like he
says it discharges itself in Apollonia
n-- images there's a play of images on
the stage that were allowed to
contemplate sometimes you know in ways
that that are going to produce happiness
and sometimes in ways that are going to
evoke fear or loathing or anger he also
discusses tragedy as being an Apollonia
embodiment of Dionysiac embodiment and
powers so this is this is a really key
idea and in in Nietzsche's view this is
an equilibrium that cannot remain stable
for long so he talks here because he
likes the sort of world historical
you know culture identifying way of
thinking about things he talks about the
Greeks managing to find a third term
between India and Rome India in his view
had focused too much on this sort of
awareness of the primal unity of things
and it led to an aesthetic rather than
an aesthetic response aesthetic meaning
life denying withdrawing from the world
you know you think about you know the
sort of the key ideas that are getting
to Europe about coming from sabia Panna
shads or from from other Hindu
philosophy or from Buddhism a lot of it
coming to them through Schopenhauer Rome
represents the opposite and where
everything is very worldly there there
might be a religion but nobody actually
takes it seriously except for those dumb
pagans who are you know the country
people the lower classes the the priests
laughs to themselves as Cicero tells us
as they're carrying out their sacrifices
and and these soaps so to the people who
are you know drawing Oracle's by by
cutting open the entrails of birds the
Greeks managed to find a third term
that would respond to the the problem of
life in a very dynamic way by bringing
together the Apollonia and the DNA ciick
into a dynamic tension and this
unfortunately lasts only for a few
generations so he says that it was
through tragedy that myth achieved its
profound his content its most expressive
form and that that's an interesting way
to to describe it isn't it so Prometheus
is really a great example of this you
know if you've read ashe Alice's play
Prometheus Unbound it's often you know
bundled together with with the book of
Job and I think that's kind of a nice
companion piece for that in part because
they're both dealing with the problem of
suffering and justice and the role of
the gods in relation to to man or the
divine if you like
what Nietzsche says this reveals is an
insoluble conflict between human beings
and gods competing claims of justice
there is no single universal justice
that is able to take them all in instead
even the gods or you might say that in
some respect at war with each other
you know prometheus is actually one of
the Titans one of the Titans who did not
fight on their side against the gods
you know Zeus and people like that but
he's going to be punished by Zeus for
what for bringing fire to human beings
for setting human beings not quite equal
to God but at least on some sort of
footing and you know if we think about
what's going on and what nietzsche is
identifying there we might call to mind
the other plays of these two authors
with Sophocles who comes to mind
immediately probably Oedipus and the
entire Oedipus sequence with Aeschylus
we have the the you know sequence as
well
beginning with Agamemnon and there's
there's quite a few other great plays in
there as well Sophocles has the Ajax and
so we might want to take a look at these
in the light of what Nietzsche has to
say now I mentioned the the Apollo nyan
and the Dionysian as two noble responses
to life is this is the way Nietzsche
views it what about this Socratic
response how does that arrive on the
scene this is also equally important in
in the birth of tragedy as a matter of
fact this is really what the core of the
work is about it's not just about our
things Apollonia nor Dionysian it's
really about how this third thing comes
in and really mixes things up so let's
talk about Socrates Nietzsche talks
about Socrates as being the spectator of
the plays being like a critic in a sense
of the older plays and he represents a
kind of optimism about rationality
and this has two sides to it a optimism
about human rationality that we in fact
can understand everything that we could
make sense out of ourselves and human
relationships and all the things that we
endure experience and then also the
rationality of existence because
Socrates treats the world as if it
actually makes sense and if you do this
sort of thing you will in fact find that
a lot of things do in fact make more
sense
the question is is this really an
adequate understanding of existence or
is it a an illusion like the other two
are and a lot of people I think miss
read this work because they they view
Socrates and his whole way of being as
just a kind of hyper Apollonian right so
you know DNS dziak represents chaos
offloading represents order irrational
rational we can go on and on and on but
Nietzsche is not saying that Nietzsche
is saying that Socrates is something
quite new going far beyond it and so we
want to think a little bit more about
what that would be and we can do that by
looking at Socrates wingman you might
say his his henchmen his sidekick
Euripides Nietzsche portrays them is
basically sort of the artistic companion
or the correlative of Socrates a mask
for the Socratic way of life and the
idea that's motivating him is to
eliminate the dnsa act as a basis for
tragedy to sort of put Socratic optimism
into everything everything can be
explained everything can be understood
everything can be made clear the way
Nietzsche frames this and this is really
kind of a brilliant way of talking I
think is he places the spectator onto
the stage and makes it so that everyone
philosophizes everybody explains what
they're doing
and they they set out there their
arguments they set out their motives
they make themselves transparent to us
he and and what happens is the DEA
initiate is replaced with mirror effect
and emotion and the Apollonian he
Nietzsche says gets replaced with cold
ideas with dialectic rather than actual
Apollonian play and so this leads to
tragedies death Greek tragedy Nietzsche
says perished in a manner different from
the older sister arts it died by suicide
in consequence of an insoluble conflict
the death of Greek tragedy created a
tremendous vacuum that was felt far and
wide so this includes Ripa DS and his
successors like Agathon and the new
comedy as well and as a side note
Nietzsche views platonic dialogue as
something that comes out of this is that
he calls it a mixture of all the
available styles and forms of hovered
between narrative lyric drama between
prose and poetry later he calls it the
lifeboat in which the shipwrecked older
poetry saved itself together with its
numerous offspring crowded together in a
narrow space and timidly obeying their
helmsman Socrates so that everything now
has to conform to the Socratic way of
understanding and so here we get to the
you know the key argument the key
proposal that's being made by this work
socrates leads into what nietzsche is
going to call Alexandrian culture and
what he means by this is sort of the the
culture that spread itself across not
only the Greek world but also the Roman
world in and it's essentially a Socratic
culture it's lost its connection with
the DNA siak and the Apollonian insofar
as its culture there might still be DNA
see and rights being celebrated in
different places there might still be
some people doing something Apollonia
but they're really sideline so he says
our whole modern world and he's writing
this remember back in the 1870s is
caught in the net of Alexandrian
she recognizes as it's ideal the man of
theory equipped with the highest
cognitive powers working in the service
of science and his archetype and
progenitors Socrates he also notes that
this Alexandrian culture is beset by
Bennett by an internal contradiction it
requires a slave class in order to
function but it also undermines the very
legitimacy of that reliance upon the
slave class which leads to all sorts of
social conflicts he views our present
age and again he's writing this in the
1870s right so we should keep this in
mind when we think about how we apply it
to our own our present age is a Socratic
one where one aim has been the
destruction of myth you know turning
everything public turning everything
transparent democratizing everything we
might look at our own effects of say the
Internet
and think about you know what Nietzsche
would have to say about that
and he says Socratic culture is kind of
drawing to a close it's becoming aware
of its own limitations its own FAL
ability and we're beginning to encounter
fear of its own consequences if we do
adopt this optimism this rationalism do
we find that it empties out the world of
significance it also begins to realize
that its foundations are not as solid as
it presents them as being and so this is
where we're going to end this is where
Nietzsche ends and he criticizes this
later I mean so this German music is
going to save us German music and
philosophy both are destroying the
socket ISM that dominates culture so you
know cut through Schopenhauer is an
example of this in philosophy the whole
progression all the way up to vogner is
an example of this by the way I'll
mention that he considered opera a
totally Socratic way of doing music and
he thought it was without any cultural
value at all he doesn't mean Wagner's
opera he means sort of the traditional
opera so you know a new fusion he think
so Apollonian and Dionysian meet in
music and i think he really did see at
that time vogner's gazhams constricted
the total the total art work as a way of
pulling this off
he gives us an example of this Deana
siak dissonance you know the attention
to how you use dissonance in music which
was becoming quite a you know major
topic if you think about late classical
music so now we reach the time for
dedicated Question and Answer
feel free to unmute yourself and ask
whatever questions you like or to put
your questions in the chat function and
I will take each of them in turn and
we'll go through them
Alfredo asks do you think for Nietzsche
Socrates represents modernity yeah I'd
say he represents modern culture and the
driving if we want to think in terms of
technology the driving force behind our
technologies and the optimism that we
have about how technology is going to
you know transform everything I mean we
kind of live in a day when this is so
overblown that it's the object of skits
you know where every new platform that
somebody creates there's hype about this
is going to education will never be the
same after this right and and you know
now we've gone through a couple waves of
this and we you see that that's mostly
fluffer II but a lot of people actually
do believe that fluffer II and I would
say that they may in part do believe it
in part because they identify with what
Nietzsche is calling this Socratic
impulse I do want to point one thing out
Nietzsche does not think it's very clear
that everybody is either like an Apollo
nyan or a DNS deaq or a Socratic or that
all cultures are necessarily this way he
says that there's other you know more
common in meaning low-class
responses as well to the problems of
life he doesn't go into any discussion
of them because he's mostly interested
in you know describing these three but
he you know he says that there there
there so the person who's always on the
make is not really Socratic is not
really DNS dziak is not really Apollonia
but they're they're a big part of our
culture as well so what would I guess
what you could say Nietzsche thinks is
lacking in our culture is the D&E siak
right but also the Apollonian whenever
we do in fact encounter something that
that comes as a counter foil to the AP
the DN a-- c act there's a tendency for
it to be something Socratic instead of
Apollonia the Apollonia imposes order
but doesn't demand that that order be
turned into something universalized
be turned into something justified to
everybody and i think that that's that's
something that we we lose sight of in
our culture so yeah good good question i
mean another thing I should point out
too is in his later works Nietzsche is
going to sort of go back on this notion
of Socrates as being noble you know in
like beyond good and evil and in other
places he's going to say Socrates really
represents the you know the the herd the
lower class is taking over
all right Scott's got a good question
here how would each of you later music
like say Schoenberg neighboring stock
house and there was an order to that
music but very dissonant probably to his
ears well you know you know so we're
talking about Nietzsche mentioning the
role of dissonance as being something
that in our own time we could like
contribute so that we could maybe
understand the Dena siak better right we
could do it better I think that
Nietzsche would have been you know if
you lived longer like let's say he
hadn't gone insane and he lived well
into the 20th century and had engaged
modern music he probably would have had
to evolve a more complex theory so yeah
I mean we might think about somebody
like like you know how would he deal
with prokofyeva Shostakovich as well you
know Sharon Berg would really be I
suppose somebody of interest to him
where he's doing the you know 12 tone
and you got to go through each of them
first was how does that actually
represent something to us how did what
is it what does it provoke in us
Scott follows up he talks about music
that his self absorbed he didn't like
music that was from oneself is that
correct well he thought that if you're
you know a lot of people at the time had
this idea that music was like the
expression of our emotions and you'd
sort of you know pull it out of yourself
and each was like that's just you know
claptrap that's that's the sort of thing
that that people who are not really you
know producing important music that's
the sort of thing they tell them to
follow us and this is the sort of thing
that music teachers tell their students
when they indoctrinate them ya need you
know in a way you can only really
produce great music when you are working
with more than just you know what you've
got when you've got some sort of
cultural inheritance that you're
struggling with and transforming mate
right so what would need to think about
bebop and jazz I wouldn't even know
where to start I suspect that that he
might I mean when we think about JSO
jazz is kind of an equivocal term it
covers so many different things there
might be there might be some genres of
it that that Nietzsche would be
interested in are okay with but I
suspect that he would probably dismiss
most of it unless he was
they like put in a jazz club and could
observe you know the musicians working
together in virtuosity and maybe then
he'd see it as something where you have
a fusion of Apollonian and and D&S the
act I don't know I mean what if we think
about like you know smooth jazz I think
he would take a listen to that and be
like well this is pretty saccharine
stuff yeah Scott right that makes sense
so he doesn't think youth would create
great good art because of no life
experience it doesn't that doesn't
really come up in here I don't see
anything that would preclude youth from
creating good art although in a life
experience would certainly make make
what they're working with deeper right
particularly when we're thinking about
tragedy where you've got not just you
know a certain musicality to it and
movement to it but but primarily as
Aristotle identified thought involved in
the characters and then of course you
have the plot but you know youths can be
quite involved in in their you know
their the culture that they inhabit and
some some youth seem really old beyond
their years so so I hesitate to say that
he and I'm something he really just
doesn't talk about that much in this
text all right what other questions have
you guys got for me
all right so here's a complicated one
Nietzsche defines and characterized
these two figures DNS yet not Apollonia
from historical perspective and a
conceptual one using his confirmed
experience in philology in your view how
would define a figure in art and how
does Nietzsche get along with it from
the past philosophical tradition
Schopenhauer Conte and Hegel how would
how would and guessing there's a couple
words missing here how would one define
a figure in art and how does okay so I'm
not sure what the question is actually
asking so I'll take a stab at it I mean
nature thinks that certain genres and
certain elements of say tragedy rDNA
Seon or Apollonia when the two of them
are coming together they are being
transformed to some degree right they're
not just what they are in some sort of
pure void they're they're always within
life within culture and often in
relation to each other so I hope that
goes to answering the how would one
define a figure in art I'm not quite
sure with that that means how does
nature get along with it from the past
philosophical tradition
so you mentioned Schopenhauer and Hegel
nature criticizes this book as being a
little too high galleon later on and you
know in a sense I guess that that makes
some sense you know what you're talking
about here is something like a dialectic
between the Apollonian and the DNA siak
something that I think he's going to
work out you know in better detail later
on and he sees it as a little too
schematic which which kind of fits Hegel
as well I'm sure
Pantani is definitely very important in
this because he's drawing on some some
ideas from Schopenhauer about the the
nature of life and suffering but he
wants to avoid Schopenhauer's sort of
pessimism he wants a more dynamic
pessimism pessimism of strength like
like you know I had in that very early
passage
Alfredo asked what would Socrates have
thought about Nietzsche
I guess it's bends in which Socrates
were looking at if we're talking about
Plato's Socrates or for talking about
sin upon Socrates because you know the
portrayals are somewhat different
okay so Plato's Socrates I suppose that
Socrates could respond that that you
know he could he'd probably have to say
yes you've got me on this point in this
point in this point but I think you're
fundamentally wrong about the nature of
existence or or the way to God's work or
things like that I don't think that you
would get an extremely productive
dialectic going between Socrates and and
Nietzsche I mean it's hard to it's hard
to think about how somebody from back
then would come back I don't know though
if you think maybe Socrates would have
would have you know imagine that like
less in terms of nature right imagine
Socrates could have come back like a
hundred years after his death and seen
what was happening in Greece and in the
different schools that were claiming to
be Socratic maybe he would have taken a
look at that and said I don't like
everything I or he might he might have
thought it was pretty cool I don't know
but for me that that's a tough one
Nate if anything you think Nietzsche got
totally wrong in this
books that's a good question totally
wrong I don't even really agree with
Nietzsche on some of his self-criticism
I think it's a better book than he
thought it was later on I guess you know
there's there's places you know I think
he's a little bit too given to you know
this this kind of cultural
generalization about say Rome or India
you know dealing with these in these
really really high-level abstractions
you know he's describing a history
that's pretty complicated and he's doing
a pretty good job at certain points and
then I think he's kind of
oversimplifying it at other points and I
I'm not totally sold on your Ripa T's
being as bad as Nietzsche makes him out
to be I don't know if I see as much of a
radical break between Euripides and his
predecessors but but then again I'm not
you know I'm not a classicist so maybe
he's you know he certainly spent more
time with those texts than I did so I
don't know I hesitate to say that he got
that wrong I'd be interested to hear
what other people think he got wrong in
this book what I will say though is that
the reception of this book and the
reading of this book has very often
portrayed Nietzsche as like setting up a
dualism between the Apollonia and the
DMS siak and you know like you know even
down to the point of view if you like
google it today you're going to find
like one of them identified Vienna ciick
is I think right brain is supposed to be
the creative brain left brain is is the
logical or I might be mixing them up and
people will often set this up
particularly people
the arts who want to read this book and
that's clearly not the the story that
Nietzsche is telling there's a lot more
going on there the Socratic is
particularly important the other thing
that he says that I'm going to talk a
bit more about this in the the the
seminars is that he tells us that the
Greek DNA siak is not the exactly the
same thing as the barbarian DNA ciick
the barbarians just kind of you know
they go into this crazy frenzy and
they'll do just about anything whereas
the Greeks you know it's a little bit
better channeled you could say I suppose
well then let me
well if well anybody is thinking about
this all mental I'll mention that I've
got a boy it really Scrolls fast you
know I've got an each a playlist in my
main youtube channel I'm going to be
adding to that you know some more core
concept videos but if you're really
interested in the birth of tragedy I've
got four one-hour videos on that
specific work and also a nice talk that
I was asked to give a few years back for
the Pell Honors Program at one of the
college's out east
Trenton blanking on the name at present
I can remember the place it's not
Felician another one of those sort of
names and then of course we're doing the
two-hour deep deeper dive online
seminars on this topic coming up this
Saturday ah there's a few other
questions so let me go back to those
very quickly
in what sense was that work of trouble
for the academics of his time I wouldn't
say it was a trouble that implies that
they would take it seriously enough to
be troubled by it and I think most of
the academics of his time more or less
ignored it and you know it's a
challenging work it's putting forth kind
of a very new and radical
reinterpretation of things and
typically academics unless they're
really into that and it fits their their
their particular narrative that they
already want to tell they they tend to
ignore stuff like that
alfredo asks is there any relation
between Nietzsche and Epictetus and the
concept of nature no I would I wouldn't
say so there's there's this really
interesting line that gets quoted all
the time over and over again by people
in the stoic forums where Nietzsche's
you know ripping into the Stoics for you
know their conception of nature
Nietzsche and the Stoics just have very
different conceptions of nature
Nietzsche's not getting his conception
of nature from the Stoics he's getting
it from from other sources Holly asked
did Nietzsche revise this material in
his positions in later works yeah he was
continually revising his position like I
said there's a you know an attempted
self-criticism at the beginning of this
work where you can see his own take
later on on what he thought was lacking
or went too far in this work
Dionysus keeps coming up he doesn't talk
all that much about the Apollonian as
such in those terms
from that point on but he does talk a
lot about you know imposing order and
and you know force and things like that
which is the tied together with the
Apollonian and like I mentioned the
Socratic winds up no longer being a
noble response but sort of an ignoble
how the masses or the you know the
people filled with reason to not get
there get there their licks in for
Nietzsche and later works and he really
revises his picture of Socrates as being
you know kind of a humble and not humble
in the good sense humble as in like you
know the man of the mass who rises up
and takes over all right so I'll mention
as I bring this to a close if you
enjoyed this free webinar you might want
to consider becoming a supporter of my
work on on patreon and there's a link
down below glad of all of you could
attend a good question
and I hope to see you in some of our
online events down the line